-Melissa,
you're up next.
-Alright.
-Pull the mic, spin the wheel.
Let's see what we're
playing tonight.
-Alright.
[ Rattles ]
♪♪
-Alright, come on, come on.
There we go.
Ooh!
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yes!
Alright.
-♪ Wheel of Musical
Impressions ♪
♪ Wheel of Musical ♪
♪ Impressions ♪
-Now, for this one,
you're going to get an artist
and then you're going to have
to sing a song
while doing
an impression of them.
-Oh, my God.
So hard.
-You're very good
at impressions.
Let's see what you get here.
[ Rattles ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
This is how this is going
to work here.
Let me tell you.
You're going to sing a song.
-Different artists will pop
on the screen in front of you
and you have
to change impressions
each time you see a new name.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[Indistinct] Melissa Villaseñor.
-Alright.
Jam Band, can we get a little
"Uptown Funk"?
Your first impression is
Miley Cyrus.
Melissa, take it away.
-♪ Doh doh doh ♪
♪ Doh doh doh, doh doh ♪
-Miley Cyrus.
-♪ Doh doh doh ♪
-♪ Ahh ow! ♪
-♪ This hit, that ice cold ♪
♪ Michelle Pfeiffer ♪
-Wow!
-♪ That white gold ♪
-She's amazing.
-Wow!
-♪ This one ♪
♪ For them hood girls ♪
♪ Them good girls,
straight masterpieces ♪
♪ Stylin', wildin' ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Livin' it up in the city ♪
♪ Got Chucks on
with Saint Laurent ♪
♪ Gotta kiss myself,
I'm so pretty ♪
[ English accent ]
I'm too hot.
-♪ Hot damn ♪
-Call the police
and the fireman.
[ Laughter ]
I'm too hot.
-♪ Hot damn ♪
-Julie Andrews?
-Make a dragon
wanna retire, man.
I'm too hot.
-♪ Hot damn ♪
-Say my name.
You know who I am.
I'm too hot.
-♪ Hot damn ♪
-And my band about that money.
Bring it down.
♪ Girls hit your hallelujah ♪
-♪ Whoo whoo ♪
-♪ Girls hit your hallelujah ♪
♪ 'Cause Uptown Funk
gon' give it to you ♪
♪ 'Cause Uptown Funk gon'
give it to you ♪
♪ 'Cause Uptown Funk
gon' give it to you ♪
♪ Saturday night
and we in the spot ♪
♪ Don't believe me?
Just watch ♪
♪ Come on! ♪
♪♪
♪ Don't believe me?
Just watch ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey! ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow!
Wow!
That is what I'm talking about!
Oh, my God!
-That's fantastic!
-You crushed it!
You crushed it with the
standing O right there.